pendant la
marche j'ai j'ai aidé et j'ai été aidé
et vous vous êtes laissé
faire incroyable ouais ouais ouais j'ai
écouté vos paroles et je me suis dit
prends cette montée comme une nouvelle
sève tu es une nouvelle personne et tu
n'as pas de mal à renaître puisque tout
revient tout neuf tout rentre tout neuf
donc je me suis dit maintenant tu es
toute neuve et confiance en toi ne sois
pas complet
ne n'ai pas peur de déranger quelle est
l'évolution qu'on voit quelle est
la est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui a
bougé oui oui oui je pense que je lâche
certaines choses je pense
que bah déjà je suis je suis forcément
face à moi-même dès le matin on se
regarde et on se dit ah bah ta copine
aujourd'hui c'est toi si tu veux parler
à quelqu'un c'est toi si si tu veux
aimer quelqu'un c'est toi donc en fait
euh